أنت تعرف أن هذا هو المستشفى العاشر الذي
كنت فيه.
يجب على العائلات أن تعيش بعد هذا
والألم الذي يمر
بعيدًا جدًا
ومن الصعب حقًا
تحمله.
لقد أصابهم
الحزن جميعًا الحزن الجماعي
الذي نعيشه جميعًا ولرؤية هذه
العائلات
التي تقاتل من خلاله وتثابر
وتضطر إلى إقامة هذه
الجنازات في مواقف السيارات
مثل تلك التي أظهرتها لنا.
صدمة جماعية نعيشها جميعًا
، وسارة ، نحن جميعًا نقدر القلب
الذي تجلبه إلى هذا
كل يوم بالإضافة إلى
تقاريرك الممتازة ،
شكرًا ، ليس جيدًا ، ليس من الجيد
ما نفعله لكل منهما
لا ينبغي أن تذهب هذه العائلات إلى
هذا ، فلا يجب أن تمر
هذه العائلات بهذا الأمر ، لذا يرجى الاستماع إلى ما تقوله هذه
العائلة ،
لا تدع هذا أنت تفعل كل ما
في وسعك لمنع هذا من قتل
أفراد عائلتك وجيرانك
وأصدقائك  ومعلميك وأطبائك
ورجال الإطفاء كل هؤلاء الأشخاص موجودون
هنا لمساعدتك
ولكن عليك أن تقوم بدورك يا سارة
لن نتمكن من رؤيتها
بوضوح دون إبلاغك ،
لذا شكرًا جزيلاً لك
أه جميعًا نشعر به  أنت تلقي
بظلالها على
جميع المراسلين الذين يذهبون
إلى المستشفيات
وقمت للتو بعمل رائع بالنسبة
لنا ، لذا شكرًا جزيلاً لك
واعتني بنفسك ، شكرًا
لك